the vegas golden knights opened training
camp today ron futrell visited city
national arena where fans were visiting
for the first time in a long time yeah
here we go kirsten you could see it you
could feel it the energy the fans had it
the players felt this energy year five
for the vegas goal the knights and
knights dropped the puck on the 2021
season today a few changes this year no
more marc-andre fleury no more ryan
reeves but still they got the lizard
there's a mascot
the team hopes to do better than the
western conference finals that they had
the last two seasons for the best news
of the day it felt like things were
getting back to normal
i'm excited to have a normal camp and as
normal a season it was so great to have
the fans in the building last year in
the playoffs and the excitement
the game's not the same without full
buildings and you know we we were
fortunate enough to get to that point
last year and it was it was awesome all
right the nice welcome to newcomer
center patr nolan patrick he's number 41
in the dark here first preseason game is
sunday
seven o'clock against the san jose
sharks at t-mobile arena then they play
for rio
october 12th the t-mobile arena against
the newest expansion team or maybe that
other expansion team you could say the
seattle kraken kirsten